I'm Chris waters and we're back on the
live stage day three of GameSpot's live
coverage of e3 continues now we're
getting into some dying light joining me
is Matt it magic the lead game designer
from tech land we're going to be playing
some dying light talking about it and
you guys have been showing this off to a
lot of folks here at e3 and people
actually been getting to play it oh yeah
so we have a press demo which focuses
you know in the previous demos we would
focus on you know showing you what the
game is all about the day and night
cycle this time around we're focusing on
the player progression how can you
develop your character and how does that
actually influence the choices that you
make in the game because depending on
which abilities you decide to unlock you
will have to do tackle the game
differently yeah and let me just say I'm
so super excited to be here it's
absolutely awesome we're really glad to
have you on stage happy thank you for a
fun - like - sort of like bask in the
energy of e3 and especially when you
have a game that people are getting
excited about show off that must be
excellent yeah now dying light I you
know you talk about player progression
and the choices players will make in
terms of customizing their character
give us an idea of the range of sort of
game gameplay you can cover the in terms
of the customization because there's you
have the parkour you have the zombie
killing you have the the environmental
manipulation and there's a flexion play
here yeah yeah so just it just
considering the character we have two
basic proficiencies so agility and
strength and the way you develop your
character is by doing so you want to get
better at agility that means you have to
run you have to jump you have to slide
and whatnot you want to get better at
strength that means combat that means a
lot of broken bones and smashed skulls
and cut off limbs a lot of blood gushing
and so if you accumulate enough of
experience in each proficiency you level
up and of course you get to be stronger
faster but the most important part is
you get to unlock this really cool
abilities and we really think about it
must game changers you know we have
about 50 of them and that's a lot of
game-changing whoa oh yeah well you know
depending on which
that depends how you want to play it
again you know we really want to behave
the players to be able to say okay this
is how I want to play the game and we
give you all the toys so you can do it
the way you want to do it so for example
you might be the person who doesn't
really feel like fighting ah so yeah you
know in real life when zombies show up
I wouldn't grab a thing and smash and no
I would be running away really fast see
you later yeah so for example you can
unlock number of abilities that if you
get in trouble you can you know slide
full-speed under stuff you can jump off
them be able to dodge then throw them
away on the other hand you might just
feel like no I'm feeling confident about
just killing stuff yep so there you go
you go a special kind of attacks stabs
360s and you know there's so much stuff
when we'll be able to see some of that
in that demo all right well let's get
right into it we got a chunk of gameplay
demo that someone's gonna be playing in
the back and the odd says old town here
on the screen set the stage for us where
is this located and actually we had a
question coming over Twitter earlier
about that I'm going to look it up you
set the stage for us alright so this is
actually a part of the game that we've
never shown before that this e3 this is
the first time we're showing it it has a
completely different vibe to it
it's much more vertical it's it's an old
town so you can expect Beauty kind of
decay because it's still quarantine but
you know little cafes shop tall
buildings all right let's just jump
right into the action you missed the
chance to see dive right into the action
man yeah I thought it up totally sorry
my English is not that good just yet
quick question from ollie about the
setting is this it's Haram is the name
of the place yes
and is this based off of real Istanbul
oh yeah if someone was one of our
references yeah we really think that you
know
city at the brink of West and East has
it through unique flavor
it feels really flesh fresh for the
billion video games so yeah that was
that was one of the biggest references
we had one says oh yeah here again I
don't know if you notice uh we brought a
crafted weapons with us this is
something very on a straight off the
shelf spiked bad outerwear and I would
call it a classic it's very simple but
effective
so yeah let's let's write perhaps we
will see like you know ripping you can
actually rip pieces of meat right of
them oh and if you aim it just right
yeah that was both broke the bone yes
well I like it echoes of MORTAL KOMBAT
oh yeah so that was actually that was
actually a combo yeah that was two
abilities first one was jumping right
off them running on their heads yes and
while you launch yourself you can combo
it with an aerial attack when you smash
them right through that's another thing
we call it we call it as a barracks and
you can actually split a guy in half of
that now we got to make sure that they
don't come too close we hold them biters
for a reason yeah that's another special
video we call it that was like a well
swinging it all the way over 360 so we
can take the whole group with them okay
say no now though I like yeah yeah go
ahead now this one looks like it's got a
little yeah yeah yeah you can actually
grab a little pieces you know of metal
and was definite here piece of metal
duct tape and you can create something
like that we call it flame slasher so
with this thing you can actually cut
them to pieces and burn them at the same
time alright
zombie grill now of course the the the
brutalization of zombies is something
Techland is very familiar with having
the port developed the Dead Island
series I what you know in terms of what
you guys you know obviously there's the
like the just the visceral satisfaction
of like vanquishing your enemies in
these sort of jewelry ways I is that was
that sort of the driving factor there
for like letting you sever limbs and
chop them in half or do you know sort of
is there strategic element to its like
well like taking down the zombie would
take
of an effort but if I chop its leg off
with me it's not gonna be able to pursue
oh yeah well keine yeah I think it's a
waste where you guys it's always best to
go for the head yeah because you can cut
their limbs off you can cut a leg off
it's still gonna crawl for you still
gonna crawl yeah so but for example you
can choose a special ability oh I'm here
actually uh just pointing that out you
can we can actually bring the in fact
that to help us we just made a lot of
noise bring them infected to kill other
humans but coming back to your question
you could try an ability where you knock
them down and just start them on their
heads that's an easy kill again but
that's your choice you can concentrate
on breaking them like just try to have
one even have to kill him ah-huh and
yeah making the game as visceral as
possible yeah that was the idea right
from the start you know we really try to
make combat as meaty as possible you
know all these flats and breaks that's
that that's a drug that's really good
water our chicken is off the auto
repair' like that a lot you know one of
our reference was remember the movie
Ninja Assassin yes yeah you know the way
the weapons sound through all the blood
splats it was so awesome so yeah we
definitely want to bring that kind of
experience really touching it you can
feel it you know and and the weight of
weapons we really try to make it is make
you feel the difference you know it's
different if you if you use the baseball
bat it's different okay if you're if
you're swinging a pot it is different if
it's two-handed hammer whole beautiful
hatchet it's like really just fun to
watch dig these jump kicks and you know
baseball bat swings oh you saw that you
shot us man
come on seasons ah be guts I like that
they you know they aren't just limited
to being on the ground so it's not just
I'm on the roof I'm totally safe no
because that gives you the chance to
kick zombies off roofs which is awesome
i but we did see something earlier that
i would like to ask you about mobility
is such a huge part of this game we saw
you know walking on zombie
sort of parkour stuff mantling on
surfaces climbing up walls there was
like a grappling hook yeah I think yeah
right so talk about that a little bit
and how that sort of opens things up for
players right well you know grappling
code brings yet another level of how you
can traverse through the wall and yeah
that we you know you don't get it from
the start but as you progress as you get
better you start to be really smooth at
traversing but still you will find
yourself in situations that well you
know you can find we're running to a
dead end
uh-huh and having that thing it's a
lifesaver to look and there you go of
course you can also use it offensively
like you can you know grab somebody's
leg and just pull it off the roof it
seems like so much of this is just you
guys thinking of what would be like
really funny goofy nasty ways to just so
you have you have no idea you know we
have people showing up at the office and
they're like you know what I I was
taking a shower and I have this really
awesome idea that will be so cool to do
this and we're like yeah let's do it
let's do it all right magic I have a
bunch of questions coming in on Twitter
so when I fire Matt you're right quick
uh one of them sort of ties into that
that mobility we're talking about
Stephanie Harden wants to know about
fall damage being an issue like how you
know if you're if you're falling off a
roof how do you guys you take damage
from that or can you drop a significant
distance or can you land on safe spots
how does that work all right so well if
you fall from two big high you're gonna
die
okay uh what such is life but there are
a number of objects that you can use to
break your fall a number of them were
visible in the demo let's go saw an
awning over like a little Anderson tan
or a bags of trash or a car a car roof
there's a bunch of stuff that you can
use to break your fall all right on top
of them there's a number of abilities
like free running abilities that you can
use to be able to not die while falling
so for example a roll a lot of people
was asking can I perform roll and all
people do that yes you can all right got
a few more I
how can you upgrade your weapons Stewart
wants to know we sort of touched on that
a little bit with you know slapping the
battery to the axe the lighter to the
machete thing yeah there was is that
stuff that you are do it you're finding
in the environment and crafting similar
to Dead Island yes
so you while you exploring the game you
find load a little piece of metal here a
little duct tape some wire a gassing and
then you can combine it all together
yeah and you can create weapons that
feel you know that suit your place like
right so you know you kind of feel like
the guy that likes heavy weapons so you
can upgrade your your access to make as
much damage as you can with those you
can use knives you know we have like
hundred of base weapons so and then
pretty much you can modify them all so
so lots of options there five specially
from Daejeon wants to know on off
Twitter how does the game change when
you play co-op well first of all it just
gets more awesome like you know it's
everything you do with friends it makes
it that much more awesome it just gets
better I mean that's one of the maxims
of game design I think yeah so um well
you know that depends how you want to
play it okay so you feel like
cooperating um that's good you can you
know try completing missions together
you're going to actually help each other
for like in night situations you know it
affected our attracted to noise so you
could let's say we played together you
can grab a machete start banging it at
the door Lord a infected from one place
to another and then we can sneak
together around it or maybe we feel more
like let's bring them here I'm gonna be
debate and you drop the bomb or
something uh then we might say you know
what we're going to take these two
sideways I'm going to finish this one
you're gonna finish this one and then
we'll meet somewhere else
very clean on top of that we have our
pre-order incentive this is the mode
that we call beat is ami uh-huh and
that's pretty much what it says you get
to play as this super infected and
what's what's cool about it is you get
to join other people's games like when
they're playing they they're just
regular game as you
and then you show up and you come after
them yes your nasty zombie self
absolutely all right so that's a
pre-order bonus yes and so pre-orders
are open now but when is the game coming
out Bank light is going out in February
2015 and it's going to be on next-gen
consoles or pretty much everything so
360 ps3 Xbox one ps4 and PC excellent
motsek thank you so much for coming on
stay here for much who have having a lot
of fun man
looking forward to it